the fourth of july is right around the
corner and batch and bottle is gonna
make your celebration a lot easier with
their new pre-made cocktails here to
tell us more is this is sebastian their
mixologist welcome my friend yeah thank
you very much for having me it's great
to have you so what what are these
pre-made cocktails listen i'm going to
make your life a lot easier i'm doing
the hardest part of the job right now
it's just literally
this is it
well we got here it's a luxurious
pre-mixed cocktail made with some of the
most iconic brand in the world reika
vodka hendrix gene the glenfiddich
whiskey which is one of the most awarded
single malts and all you need to do is
to chill to pull and to garnish okay
which what drinks do you guys offer oh
we have a cosmopolitan so rhubarb
cosmopolitan we have a glenfitting
manhattan we have a hendrix martini and
we have a lazy old-fashioned with monkey
shoulder whiskey oh good drinks for the
fourth of july yes i'll follow your lead
just pop it open and you know what we're
gonna have a bit of a we're gonna have a
bit of fun here we're gonna start with
the martini okay together we're gonna
make live on tv the fastest martini ever
made we're setting records today on las
vegas now you ready yeah i'll let you do
i'll let you do that i'll let you be
honest please
beautiful it's ready to go pre-batched
how much is in here uh
you can make three like oh sorry four to
five cocktails per bottle okay so right
now you just made one you got three more
to go and then you garnish look
that's it
and you're putting you just you just
made two martinis wait you put a
cucumber is that a cucumber cucumber yes
because hendrix is made with a senses of
roses and cucumber it's a little twist
you know in a gin category and it's just
add some vegetable and bright aroma it's
just that i swear you dropped the
cucumber in there the smell it came out
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so
see it smells there obviously we made on
the moose
add it to the meat a little touch on the
tongue feels good okay what do you have
next fourth of july so we have all lazy
old-fashioned here right because in all
fashion it's a long thing too you have
sugar you have to put it better and look
at all the the tools you're going to
need at home right okay yeah so wait
this is what you need to make
what you'll need this is you don't need
this stuff and that's what most of the
people yeah they don't want to make
cocktail because i'm like i don't have
the tool i don't have the craft i don't
know who's got this at their
don't even have one's at my house
exactly it's a model stick and look
that's it just put some ice in there
uh-huh
right
you guys
make it so easy
and then
you shake it up or no no you don't have
to okay just ready yeah
how much did you put in well you put
like two ounces yeah okay it's a proper
problem you want to do a proper like
okay i'm home i'm doing it this is me
i'm doing my old fashion
right yeah what are you going to still
fashion spanish little orange dust you
express the oil on top giving it a
little bit of a twist here we go that's
give you aroma extra aroma because it's
all about you know what your cocktail
look what your cocktail smell what i
like about this yeah is you don't have
to tell your friends that you have this
you want to know i'll get you one you go
in the kitchen you come out with this
and you put it down on the fourth of
july people are like whoa
because most of the time you have the
bees you have the wine in the fridge and
cocktails just too much work even if you
know to do it like me being a bartender
background if i have 20 friends at home
i don't want to make drinks for 20
people
i just want to enjoy myself with my
friend relax but drink premium cocktail
so batching bottle does all the work for
you okay i got to toss a break real fast
what's the last one
this is so good this is so quick for you
i got a little trick for you what's this
one okay this is a rhubarb cosmopolitan
made with icelandic vodka called reika
rekka so here you go you cost more all
right the ladies love that drink and
then you want to impress them yeah first
of all you have to buy the raiders uh
little you got a raiders lighter okay we
got we got fire right
fire and then
put a little fire here
press that and up that really is like
some burnt orange aroma on top of your
cocktail it looks great it smells
fantastic oh you see that yes and ladies
now your party will be like oh my god
jason
fellas too
so much my friend i appreciate it uh
what's the website real fast
we don't need the website las vegas now
we'll be right back